how you doing i'm good yeah yeah
i've never been here before
welcome to our humble little show no
cards saying applause yeah we have a we
have a card that goes
people read it uh no thanks very much
for coming thank you uh when was the
first scream didn't seem like that was
that long ago even what was it no a year
ago two years ago felt like four minutes
ago um it was a year ago exactly right
now and there are they're making this
new one which they promise is much
scarier than the first one is that right
yes sequels always have to be um scarier
and there has to be a larger body count
there has to be you know there's like a
certain certain things that you have to
do first more death this time around a
lot more death yeah just in time for the
holidays yeah
uh now they use the same convention i
guess in this movie that uh that they
had in the first one which is the killer
is calling on a cellular phone is that
right um yes he does like to communicate
through a cellular phone yeah he's
familiar with all the latest technology
uh does he um i'm curious who's the guy
who does that voice in in the movie in
this in scream two who's the guy who's
the killer's voice well it's interesting
because wes craven our director um
wouldn't tell us who the voice was i
mean where the voice was coming from and
he actually the
um
i've talked so much this week i honestly
can't talk anymore that's how that is
stop the show right here then good night
everybody
wow
[Laughter]
anyway he wouldn't see who the killer
the voice was because he didn't want to
demystify it or anything so um we were
doing this one scene where it was david
arquette and jamie kennedy and myself
and we were talking and and the killer's
voice comes on the cellular phone and
between takes you get like the real urge
to talk to the guy like who is this guy
yeah yeah so you know i'd pick up the
phone and just say what are you wearing
you'll be like
die [ __ ]
buddy
i mean yeah he would stay in character
yeah oh my god that's horrible so um
he's pretty crazy yeah i would think so
now you had some i guess some spare time
in the movie i heard that you you you
got a tattoo on the movie set or while
you were shooting the phone
i did i got a i got a tattoo in atlanta
well you know you it starts to rain for
a couple days and no no start to rain
for a couple days you play boggle that's
what you do
it's great i have a different thought
process than you i don't it's raining
tattoo that's what it's time for where
did you get the tattoo um i get next to
my belly button oh
she just said belly button
uh but uh i mean that's the thing the
umbilical locks up yeah
it's like
i apologize on behalf of america but you
know how hormones and kids uh
but what what what is the tattoo is the
little it's of a gemini signal no it's
white it's a little white tattoo i've
actually had two other ones what's a
white tattoo um
it's white it's a white ink what do you
mean i've never heard of that well
it has to be relatively you have to have
a little color in you otherwise you
won't see because it really is so i
could literally be covered with with
with white tattoos
i could have like a whole kiss mask gene
simmons thing
in white and you only see it if there's
a purple light bulb hanging in the room
wow conan's cool light bulb's off no
he's not
he's that lovable nerd again uh i didn't
i never heard of a white text yeah it's
just it's white ink they put it and it's
it's good because
then you can cover it up easily if you
have to and have you have you you have
other tattoos then you have yes but
that's the kind of the strange part
about it is i have two other ones that
i've had removed because i'm the kind of
person that would do something on a whim
and think why did i do that yeah and
then i'll have it removed and i actually
like my first tattoo cost me about
thirty dollars to put on and it's so
expensive to have them lasered how do
they do it oh they laser it off that's
insane that would hurt so much i know
but this one i will keep forever because
it's small and who gets the tattoo when
you're done with it i mean
no seriously they like they they sell
like celebrities clothes now that are
used so like dabs and stuff yeah right
the doctor puts them in a little bit
courtney cox's tattoo cool bang
uh but they they took it off with a
laser yeah that would be i wouldn't do
it it hurts it's really it hurts so
maybe all white tattoos from now on or
don't get them at all
good message for the kids yeah if it's
raining play boggle i think that's the
message for kids something we should
probably um discuss
you and i were linked romantically in
the tabloids yes which was probably uh
not great news for you is great for me
uh
uh but let's first of all put this thing
up so people know we're not kidding this
came out i don't know a couple of months
ago you actually flipped for conan
o'brien that's my favorite you can put
it down now that's all right uh
that's hanging on my wall by the way
but um what did you get for that
how much did i get for it no well come
on i was uh i was shocked by this thing
first of all because of the
implausibility of the whole thing it
said you flipped from my red hair and
freckles first of all you don't have red
hair no it's it's got like a reddish
slight reddish tint but it's really not
that red no and second of all i don't
see you like flipping for he's got red
hair and freckles
i'll break up with carrot top and go out
with him you know
it didn't seem like that plausible but
i'm curious this happens you have to
understand this happens to you
i can't believe that that's not that's
not even nice to yourself what
i'm self-deprecating wit i've built a
whole empire on it yeah trust me now
yeah it's a there's a la there's a
narrow shell of self-deprecating humor
and then inside that there's just like
55 pounds of pure ego that's right
okay i won't blow your whole thing yeah
please i've worked this whole thing out
now
you uh
but like this you're romantically linked
to people all the time this was a big
deal for me because the only this is
true story the only tabloid story that i
had had before this one was a little
blip in the globe that said conan
o'brien doesn't wash his hands after he
uses the bathroom
i'm serious so i went there was also the
you have high cholesterol oh there was
that other shocking tidbit
which just shows you like how important
i am to the tabloids but what was funny
is that this thing i went from that to
you have completely flipped over me and
you and i are at some cafe munching on
veggie burgers deeply in love and i just
wanted to thank you i don't know what
happened but it just i got a couple of
people from high school calling me up
saying like is this true you and
courtney cox knows
no that's not really true
wait
uh but uh but do you get used to that i
mean this stuff happens to you all the
time yeah i don't even you don't even
read them no that one i read and i
thought it was very funny
wait a minute that one was so comically
ridiculous you had to read it that's
what i put on my refrigerator no oh no
stop please
then yeah
please we have two people that are very
attracted to each other goofing around
now what because we have a mutual friend
exactly exactly now uh
yeah exactly don't worry about it um
you'll see uh you're writing a book i
understand um or you're thinking about
writing a book i should write a book you
should write a book yeah i want to write
a book that's called what pisses me off
by courtney cox
really yeah is this a
well just like tidbits don't you ever
like aren't there a thousand things that
you just everybody can really do that
you just piss you off well not a
thousand but yeah yeah there are there
are things yeah that irritate all of us
what kind of things are you talking
about okay like um i would like to have
sections in my book that would be you
know
maybe like men or this or whether
certain sections but like numbers for
instance uh-huh i won't stick on that
because you're going to like boot me
again
no no no this is this show has become a
lot like american gladiators don't ask
me why but uh but what do you mean like
what about men you're irritated not men
let me do my numbers thing because okay
um i don't think it'd be safe to do the
other one okay like numbers um for
instance have you ever gotten someone
would leave a message on your machine or
whatever and and numbers go in rhythms
so if your number is three one oh four
seven one two
right you can remember that right but if
on your machine they say when this
happens sometimes they'll go um okay
please call that back at three
four one seven
two four sue three
it's like how can you remember that like
they run them all together that's what
you're complaining there's a whole other
rhythm to a dude that's never this is
going to be a thick book isn't it i mean
give me a big book
no if that i'm just thinking if the
rhythm in which people recite a phone
number irritates you i would hate to cut
you off in traffic
yeah you would
what would you do
um i keep my windows open i mean up
because i'm obviously not big enough to
do anything about it but i scream very
loud you scream i get very frustrated in
traffic would you ram my car if i cut
you off no cause that would just be
stupid from my hand yeah right right so
you would just scream and scream at me
yeah i lose my temper when i'm driving
right okay
what i mean i've learned to control it
somewhat but you have a bad temper i
have a yeah you have an irish temper
yeah do you i have a really bad temper
which people don't know do you forget
things though afterwards or do you move
on do you mean do i black out and commit
murder
yeah i get really mad you're all gonna
and then i black out and i wake up and
there's blood on my hands
and they say
no that's terrible
that's exactly what i meant that's
exactly what it meant no you do get but
no you get mad and people don't know
that i guess when they you see your
persona i do get i get there's certain
things that bother me like i want the
show to be right and stuff like that so
you know i can have a little bit of a
temper there
very true oh yeah let's talk about your
uh this intrigued me because you're so
busy you're making movies
you're doing friends you must have a
really busy schedule and then on top of
it all you write for a magazine
which i didn't know i have a little
helpful hints column in a magazine
um how to control your temper
[Laughter]
it's just a little it's in jane magazine
i'm jane pratt's a friend of mine and
it's a great magazine and in the back of
it i have a little column that i like
well you know
how to do certain things like they could
be stupid things from how to get wax off
of a table you know when candles drip
right um
i was just thinking of one actually the
other day um for women
um if if you're shiny like your face is
if you're if you're shiny yeah women
like if you have like an oily skin is
that what you mean or you know let's say
you need powder because i know you might
get powder later on this evening
yes yes yeah i don't know
yes come on when your face is a little
shiny no wait a minute no i mean i you
do things for tv but it's not like i'm
in a restaurant or something or maybe
not for you that's why i said it's for
girls although this would be a helpful
hint to you too
although yeah okay i do that i mean
okay forget i said it was for girls okay
um like you know those toilet seat um
things that you sit on top of when you
pull down the paper
oh no we're going to get we're going to
get this i know what a toilet seat is
yeah i got that what toilet seat things
oh the paper you pull off the ring the
sanitary ring that uh covers the toilet
that paper is perfect for dabbing your
face not after you sit on it okay
i know someone's gonna say something
this is a tough show man
no wonder david arquette has to like
pull chickens out and stuff we don't
make him do that believe me he comes up
with that but anyway that paper is
useful for forgetting yes for like
touching your face and it will absorb
the oil how did someone find that out
that's what i'm saying right before i
came out here my hair was like piecing
and there wasn't any water so i put my
hand and i realized that coke is perfect
like hair spray i did it right before i
came out so you're like
sort of a weird macgyver kind of thing
you're backstage you're like pouring a
little coke on your hair and you've got
a sanitary toilet seat cover
ready to go chewing this chewing gum
should cover up those bags
that's not a bad idea hey
does chewing gum work to cover up bags
under the eyes no but i can imagine like
a little back here
oh my god well uh scream two opens this
friday i've heard great things about it
and friends like we even have to promote
this but we will friends every thursday
at eight o'clock p.m right here on nbc
congratulations continued success and
now come on back sometime all right all
right good to see you thank you courtney
courtney cox everybody